écolo
ni cage
nique tu vis dans la tour sunset depuis
plus d'un an bah oui ils m'adorent
là-bas et tu leur doit six cent mille
dollars oui oui j'ai trouvé une solution
à tout ça mais je vais la voir ce
nouveau rôle et quand je l'aurai alors
là tout va changer le come back ne
principal c'est d'y croire
il était au tapis d'un rock faut pas
oublier 60 secondes chrono tabiou les
crews deux noms chez 44 rien à [ __ ] de
thé cruz deux gpu volte face et les
ailes de l'enfer on a un nouveau projet
mais ça parle de quoi tu pars dans le
sud de l'espagne où tu es invité à la
fête d'anniversaire d'un gentleman très
fortunés
je ferai jamais ça nick s'est payé un
million
de le faire
c'est quoi le nom du minck à cette
maison avait alors leur avis veut que je
sauve sa femme où il veut que je le voit
sauter sa femme c'est hors de question
comprenez c'est pas ben oui non c'est
moi
[Musique]
mickey
one
je suis trop content to fail et la 607
moi c'est grotesque
je vous en donne famille dollars
c'est bien
c'est quoi le truc inspiration divine
je suis paranoïaque alors on va compter
jusqu'à toi
que vous en avez la très grosse dette à
aa
partez je ne vous oublierai jamais mon
vieux
monsieur qu'edge finalement on aurait
juste pu faire le tour oui c'est pas
faux